mary has decided to buy a new car the
local car dealership states the car
she's considering has an estimated gas
mileage of 24 miles per gallon the car
has a 12 gallon tank Mary tells her
friend that the car will travel exactly
288 miles on a full tank of gas is this
a reasonable statement why or why not
and I encourage you to pause this video
now and look at these statements and
think about is this a reasonable
statement yes or no and then justify use
one of these justifications to say
whether it is a reasonable statement or
not so let's read through each of them
so the first one says yes it is a
reasonable statement for Mary to tell
her friend that the car will travel
exactly 288 miles on a full tank of gas
and the rationale is the car can travel
exactly 24 miles per gallon times 12
gallons we see that the units a gallon
in the numerator gallon the denominator
cancel out and we're left with 24 times
12 which is 288 and the units were left
with is miles 288 miles on one tank of
gas now there's one little thing that
makes this you know the math seems right
the unit cancellation seems right the
the dimensional analysis so to speak but
it seems like the statement has has is
using a stronger assumption than what
the car dealer told her the car dealer
told her that it has an estimated gas
mileage of 24 miles per gallon here the
the to do this she would have to assume
that the car can travel exactly 24 miles
in a gallon there's a big difference
between an estimate and being exactly 24
miles and it get per gallon in the
estimate first of all they might have
rounded it when they did the tests it
might have been 20 3.9 I might have even
been 20 3.6 miles per gallon or it might
have been 24 point four miles per gallon
that's a pretty big difference you
definitely wouldn't get to exactly 288
miles the other thing is is this is this
estimate is probably based on an average
of traveling many many many miles and
different conditions you get better gas
mileage if you're on the highway or if
you're going downhill and you get worse
gas mileage if you're in traffic or if
you're going uphill or if there's a
strong headwind so it's just average
here so you can't say that's going to go
exactly 288 miles without knowing
exactly how this was measured and
frankly every car is going to be a
little bit different the octane of the
fuel will be a little bit different and
so that's why it's hard to make this
exact this assumption right over here
that the car can travel exactly 24 miles
per gallon the dealership just gave an
estimate so let's go to B yes the
estimated gas mileage of the car can be
used to calculate the exact distance the
car will travel on any one tank of gas
well no we just saw already said it's an
estimate it's roughly how far the car
can travel on a tank of gas but it's not
the exact distance the car will travel
on any one tank of gas C no it's not a
reasonable statement 24 miles per gallon
is an estimate likely rounded to the
nearest integer so it would not be
reasonable to try to calculate the exact
distance the car can travel well that's
what I think I've been saying all along
throughout this video so let's just read
D know the distance the car will travel
is found by dividing 24 miles per gallon
by 12 gallons no this is just wrong this
is wrong mathematically and this is just
troublesome on a lot of levels so D is
though is if C is the right answer D is
the wrong ggest that looks strong of all
of all of all the answers here